Peter Hitchens Weston correspondent for
the London Daily Express it seems
appropriate with all our talking about
d-day to start off asking about a
headline in the US News and World Report
summer of discontent 50 years after
d-day Bill Clinton will find the Western
Europe disenchanted with democracy
disenchanted with democracy they'll do
they mean disenchanted with the United
States talking about Jacques de lor the
president of the European Commission a
crucial moment in the history of Europe
well I didn't see it as particularly
crucial moment in the history of Europe
it's a it's a moment when everybody is
looking back at the moment to what were
in many ways better times when the
United States came as a friend and an
ally and liberated Europe but in terms
of it being a crucial moment for
democracy I feel that that may be
exaggerating things a little bit
Christopher Hitchens the article goes on
to say the revival of nationalism and
ethnic extremism the worst recession
since World War two disenchantment with
European unity and the crisis in Bosnia
are casting a deepening shadow over
Western Europe democracy and other
things are used allures everywhere is
under threat it sounds like one of those
articles that writes itself I don't know
which one which hurts us news it's us no
he probably did write itself in that
case what do you mean well you know I've
got to fill up space somehow
anniversaries always a good peg
discontent is never wrong
after all I mean you've there's never
been a summer of content that I can
remember or even the winter of one had
line boring intro I'm being major state
stage he that he picture another you
know another day another dollar at US
news would be my what I like and what I
would have stuffed in that intro while I
was doing my cliches would I remembered
a stay which this writer appears to have
forgotten to do but this was the days
when everything was so simple and the
morality of everything was so clear
which is having a favorite trope at the
moment of course nothing was more
controversial than American
participation in the Second World War
nothing was nothing was less simple and
easy and
clearer than that at the time here's
Time magazine it's all a same story that
everybody's writing this is the man who
beat Hitler what do you think of all
this time spent on d-day well I think
it's well worth remembering it was the
one incident in recent history when we
actually did manage to put the clock
back something I wish we'd do a lot more
often having been driven out of out of
Europe in 1940 in disgrace and shame we
actually came back and liberated it with
American assistance we couldn't design
it without American assistance to cool
like vermin who liberated Europe is
perhaps slightly exaggerating his role
but I suppose under the circumstances
you should you should be allowed to beat
your own drum I remember that your
father was in the Navy he lived in
Portsmouth yeah our fathers in fact
buried in the in the precincts of the
d-day chapel the chapel where um General
Eisenhower see them was had the the
service before the decision was taken to
leave Portsmouth and go ahead the only
religious service that ever actually had
to be held in secret yes they were well
it was it was before the invasion had it
got out that such a service is taking
place it would have it was given away
that the the fact that it was going to
be the following morning what did he die
oh my father
yeah oh he died of old age and then what
year 1987 and he was involved in the
preparations for the Dieppe raid for
example which was the calamitous dress
rehearsal of the thing and actually had
in many ways a very arduous war his his
vessel was the one responsible was
thinking with Scharnhorst we're proud to
say on Boxing Day of 41 43 43 excuse me
as soon one forgets and on the other
side of off every well our mother has
ancestry and central-european
Curie so there was every interest in not
letting this anniversary slide but I'm
perfectly sure that in other countries
the magazine covers are saying it was
Russia that won a war or it was really
England that won the war or was secretly
to go who won the war so for this it is
it's a slightly irritating to see the
way that people and reinterpreted but I
just to go back to my other point about
how simple everything was and hope
you'll have that kind of nostalgia
leads up just a week's worth of American
newspapers of that period will realize
how how extremely controversial and how
right it was that should have been
controversy about it then this list
search for um for a lost moral
simplicity I think is is worrying and
deceptive there's a front page story by
Bill Schmidt and the New York Times and
the headline is d-day to celebrate and
Britain's in the mood they talk about
John Miller Glenn Miller's nephew of
getting a thousand people at $37 a piece
to come dancing let me read this quote
because that's what I want to ask you
about it's from a violet right 68 year
old London woman says as hard as times
were it was such a wonderful atmosphere
in those days and it goes on to say her
toe tapping out the swing rhythm as she
took in the scene a reconstruction of
World War Two servicemen's canteen yes
well there's nothing like shared
adversity for making people happy in a
paradoxical way and I think those of us
who've actually been in circumstances
where there's been danger discomfort and
the the threat of worst danger
discomfort over the horizon remember
those times afterwards with much greater
fashion than we felt for them when we
were going through them and there's the
few small war zones that I've been in
what I am now on better terms with the
people I share this experience with than
with project anybody else she went on to
say by the way but things were so
different back then too weren't they
England used to be like a big
international firm and now well
sometimes it seems as if the country has
just gone into liquid liquid ization the
if you read the Churchill Roosevelt
correspondence you'll see that that's
actually this woman probably hasn't done
so but she's absolutely right I mean the
the most interesting front of that war
and the most relevant one to our
discussion I think is the the front
between Britain of the United States the
long battle between Churchill and
Roosevelt over who was gonna get the
British Empire and Churchill losing and
spending more time some days fighting
Roosevelt than fighting anybody else
the hinge event as that woman has sort
of grasped in a way of the war was was
the entry of United States onto the
world stage as a as a victorious
Imperial power and the collapse of
Britain which lost everything of its
Imperial Dominion in winning the war and
had to mortgage it to United States in
order to win it's an extraordinary dark
way of looking at it add the word prices
that to be paid Britain actually went
bankrupt
to all intents and purposes within about
six months of the start of real fighting
the fact that the United States was
prepared to come in and supply us with
the means of making war after that meant
that the war could continue and Hitler
could eventually be defeated which would
otherwise never have happened
you could concentrate upon the the price
which Roosevelt had to make Churchill
pay but he was largely having to make
him pay it because of his own the the
domestic pressure on him here it's a way
of looking at it which i think which i
think he leaves out a lot it was a
tremendous rescue of a country which
which had very nearly been defeated and
I don't think that anyone doubts that
Dunkirk was it was a tremendous and
catastrophic defeat which we would not
have survived without American help art
too yes our brothers and this is a week
that we're having family connections
tomorrow Abe Rosenthal and his son Andy
Rosenthal a Rosenthal a columnist for
The New York Times and former executive
editor up in New York and Andy Rosenthal
the deputy bureau chief here in
Washington on Thursday Daniel wattenberg
and his father who has has his own
television show been wattenberg and also
writes a column and then on Friday we
have a couple of husband-and-wife teams
anti grower of the Orlando Sentinel and
and also her husband Michael Moss today
who is with the macneil/lehrer Newshour
Susan Schaffer with The Associated Press
and charles bierbauer the husband was
Susan Schaffer with CNN would be a good
week to have robust and William Bennett
as well out of them why do you bring
that up because it's on everybody's
front page so what straight lost my bad
I was thinking of Stephen Cokie Roberts
for some reason the name is fashion
tonight well what about the Reston's
there's all kinds believe it or not that
can keep on going by the way you've been
here now
nine months yeah you've been here 12 his
12 years you guys see much of each other
since you've been here he's always out
of town his paper keeps him on the road
harassing the president Oh hardly the
occasional treads on the floor Brock
what do you what do you think of the
experience so far it's absolutely
marvelous it's even better than I
expected it would be it's a marvelous
country to travel run because there is
always something surprising and because
it is so huge
after the cramped feeling that you get
in Europe that everybody's been
everywhere before you've been there and
that everyone's just leaving with their
Elvis to be in a country that's a
spacious and has so many varieties and
it's so many different countries within
one border is is an amazing experience
which I can't get enough Oh on this
Tuesday morning May 31st by the way the
house will be back on June 6 the week
from tomorrow there's a report in US
news that two Road scholars are thinking
about running for president two senators
Larry Pressler really and Richard Lugar
how extraordinary both Republicans and I
brought that up because we want to ask
you both about this story in u.s. news
and I'm not I'm sorry yeah USA Today
Steve Camaro used to be the Associated
Press now with USA Today Clinton
carrying extra baggies another Road
scholar there he's on his way to Europe
this week avoidance to the draft ways
the president down look I mean I think I
think Clinton's original mistake illness
tour the one that was the real clue to
what sort of a person he is was to miss
the chance to say look when Ronald
Reagan came into power he said the
Vietnam War was a noble cause I by
contrasting the anti-war movement was a
noble cause he couldn't possibly have
done himself any more damage by making
that truthful statement and people who
despise him now would have respected him
then though they would have disagree
with him no less nobody's problem is
that is not that he was against the war
but that he was simultaneously against
the war and looking after his future
political warrior by trying to avoid the
draft without avoiding the draft
precisely but he couldn't even tell the
truth about that so it seems to me well
I said what do I say precisely I mean
that isn't
that's not really what's held against
him I don't think not that he tried to
avoid the draft but that he he wouldn't
say yes and I'm proud that I did and
there's in some ways it's unfair this
keeps on coming up about Clinton and
after all it wasn't this it would be
something else the fact is that he's the
first president with a no second world
war experience so he's bound to look a
little diminished by contrast let me to
ask you both do you think is this being
brought up by members of the press that
he avoided the draft and didn't serve or
or do you do you sense that the veterans
are are spiking this I think some people
are very passionate about it I've come
across more than more than one person in
the past couple of weeks who genuinely
feels angry that a man with this
background should be representing the
United States at the D Day
commemorations it's it's a funny thing
about President Clinton he seems to
arouse very strong passions among his
supporters and among his opponents and
not much in the way of straightforward
middle of the range liking and there are
some people and as someone who was
screaming and shouting at him at
Arlington yesterday people who are
prepared to do that because they feel so
annoyed about what he did and what he
didn't do yeah but these those sort of
people are the very people who clapped
their hands stupid for Ronald Reagan who
who insulted the memory of everyone who
died in Normandy by claiming to a fort
in the war when he had not was on
several occasions and also claiming to
have insulted also the memory of every
Holocaust region by claiming to have
taken part in the liberation of from of
the death camps and the sorts of VFW
types who now curl their little Clinton
and I curled my lip myself a bit about
it because I think he should have had
the guts to stick up for the anti-war
movement put up with this Sam Reagan and
and took part in the process of
defamation that they perhaps are now
overcompensating for by the way that one
of the last times you were here you made
a statement about Mother Teresa that's
still being talked about I bring it up
because there's a lead story this
morning in some papers this has nothing
to do with public policy although I'm
sure some of the audience would like to
talk about it Pope rejects women and
priesthood is that a headline really it
is right here on the front page of The
Baltimore Sun it's not even dog bites
man
what do you think well I mean I thought
I knew that I think okay I'm in favor of
it for this reason it means Mother
Teresa can't become a priest it's got
that to be said for wise it's got much
surprised all headed hindquarters what
is it you have you mention this before
we started you you're working on a movie
about Mother Teresa there's a program on
the British television which also sells
around the world which is called Jack
Hughes and it's where inflated
reputations or phony reputations are
taken on and know obviously Mother
Teresa's a very fat target for this
program and I'm making Azure queues
about Mother Teresa's fronting for the
savings and loan croaks being the
official confessor to the Duvalier
family in Haiti covering up for the
Albanian Stalinists justifying the
Falange fascists in Lebanon ripping off
the parishioners all the things that
everyone doesn't know about Mother
Teresa but ought to know stake might be
too good for her I yes I think I mean if
I was herb I don't believe in blasphemy
but she does and I would be crossing my
fingers all the time if I was her do you
have any comment on your brother's
feeling like Mother Teresa was realized
I just haven't researched her background
so deeply I know that she must have some
positive features is my only feeling the
you're going to say I knew I'd wonder
I'm searching for the but I haven't
found any yet
in principle I think it's true that
everyone was a Spanish saying about this
everyone has some aspect of honor
he taught to be true I've come across
some people of whom it's difficult to
prove though and she is one of them I
want to show you a photograph see if it
elicits any comment from you this
morning in the Newsweek that's the face
of for several decades of Democratic
supremacy in the House of
Representatives isn't it every seaman
crevasse on that face tells a story of
some horrible deal some some bit of log
rolling some committee appointment or
other the face almost as eloquent as the
face of Lloyd Bentsen I think he wanted
I find a growing sympathy eye whenever I
hear of a corruption charge especially
in a country which seems to be pretty
endemically corrupt when it comes to
politics I
steal activity that people are being
people are for some reason or other
raising the topic of corruption because
they want to get someone for other
reasons endemically corrupt if I've
somehow or other grown up with the
belief that especially American city
politics have a certain element of
corruption dead people voting money paid
for votes things that we don't do in
mainland Britain very much and I tended
to think that people rather accepted
that it went on and that if if that's
all that Rostenkowski is being accused
of then who's next
it yeah but he hasn't made this defense
with himself as he says he's not guilty
yeah but very often they do say oh well
they're just they just picking on me
because I'm so pro health care or
something there's a hidden agenda here
in this case he just denies it and
perhaps because he's from Illinois
people I think are more just more
inclined to believe it must be true you
know Chicago politics is renowned it's
used to scare children with to this day
Mary Jacobi in a publication that's
owned by some Brits The Economist
magazine this is roll call has a lead
story here that says Congress has strict
this ethics rules in the world according
to a new Congressional Research Service
study of twenty four nations including
Great Britain
well I'm astounded it's all I can say
about that why well I don't know this is
of course the country in which the most
important thing is to be on the right
side of the law to have a good law
lawyer to get off to be found not guilty
not to do the right thing and maybe
under under those terms they do have the
strictest rules I'm I don't think that
the the kind of money which is available
for political candidate campaigns here
is available in Britain and I think when
you have that sort of money at stake
you get corruption and I don't think
that you could conceivably argue that
this country had the strictest rules
against it unless you were reading them
in a very peculiar way let me just let
me show you the headline inside because
it has a word there I want to ask you
about us sure
be most ethical country in world
according to a study of 24 democratic
nations great day for headlines isn't it
my friend
and sometimes foe michael kinsley makes
the very good remark kids knees law of
washington which is the scandal it's
never what's illegal scandals always
what's legal what what surprised me the
first time I ever came to Washington and
surprises mr. is how it isn't unlawful
to give money to a congressman to vote a
certain way it's considered legal its
most illegal to solicit the money in
that way to thus if that's legal it's
very hard to say what the ethics are
gonna be I think I think of law
compelling lobbyists to hand over their
checks to congressmen and Senators on
the floor of the of the two houses
immediately after the votes in which
they have obliged them would probably be
a salutary one yes and for the guys to
get around with taxi meters on their
lapels to click up the rate by the way
it looks like some kind of battle not
ribbons but something that would you'd
get in some kind of a battle on your on
your lapel there can you tell us what
those are well that's the shield of
Bosnia I don't know quite how they got
the fleur-de-lys is there as the emblem
that's very ancient kingdom Bosnia as
you know I'm a beam during the Crusades
perhaps I know that the other one the
other one is in a way the battlefield
decoration it's a present from the wine
waiter at a restaurant in Washington
Heights suppose were just impressed by
my services to his industry and want you
to share what motivated you to put it on
this morning it was on when I grabbed my
jacket and ran for the cab thinking
Christ it'll be a clock in a minute and
I mustn't let the Airways be monopolized
by The Daily Express there are a couple
of heat there was a criticism via from
the freight service there there's a
couple of editorials lead editorials and
a couple of papers that are known to
have liberal political philosophies and
I just want to read a little bit this is
in the New York Times have you seen this
the reformer vanishes
instead of fighting to dismantle
Washington's big money system President
Clinton has helped his party become its
biggest beneficiary pledges to clean up
the nation's campaign financing
procedures notwithstanding mr. Clinton
has expended expended more time and
energy courting well-to-do donors at
fancy private receptions than prodding
Congress to enact serious political
reform well quiet and it
it's rather adds on to what I was just
saying he they also have a list of the
presidents they call it the president's
helpers federal law limits individual
campaign contributions to one thousand
and Bars any corporate or labor union
gifts these rules do not apply to soft
money given to the national parties here
are some of the largest donors to the
Democratic Party July 1992 through March
1994 and they I'll show the audience a
second list the first donor is Time
Warner Inc five hundred and eight
thousand dollars National Education
Association 339,000 the Mastin Tucket
pick wood tribe I'm saying that right
three hundred thousand that we gambling
gambling Club Archer Daniels Midland 270
thousand Carl Lindner 250 thousand why
would the New York Times do a editorial
like this that takes off after the
Democratic Party well that page has
improved a bit since power range how
rains started tightening it up and he
still knows well if he speaks and he's a
you know the southerner named I suspect
a Democrat himself the time for that
editorial though would have been about
two years ago when the that same page
was calling mr. Clinton the front-runner
and urging him upon everybody and the
only reason he was the front-runner was
cause he understood how to win the money
primary and he'd gone and and signed up
all the heavy hitting donors before a
single version been cast that's why they
called him the front-runner and I wish
the times had been as eloquent about him
then as it is now but at the time the
only person pointing any of that out was
Jerry Brown who was called a crank by
the same paper in the same space so I'm
not particularly impressed who doesn't
know that
in other words MCA
they make movies $250,000 the Walt
Disney Company $250,000 Communications
Workers of America 229,000 Edgar
Bronfman moon Alan's 15% of Time Warner
and is the feature like Ken Auletta on
the cover of The New Yorker this week
any further comment on this itself but
there was also the matter of whether
people who had worked with or for the
President as advisers would could carry
on being lobbyists while they were still
having white house net tags and there's
been a lot of discussion lately about
the frequency with which they use the
revolving door
people like Betsy rice and others well
actually there's a the Washington Post
has it editorial called ins and outs
representative Frank wolf was a
Republican over here in Arlington
Virginia has pointed youthfully and he
wrote an op-ed piece to a weak spot in
the disclosure and other rules meant to
protect against conflict of interest in
the conduct of government business it
involves the White House consultants who
cluster around every modern president
just as surely as does the White House
staff because the consultants aren't
government employees they aren't subject
to the same reporting and other such
protective rules as the presidential
aides and they're talking about James
Carville and Paul Begala
and Mandy Grunwald this bother you what
it bothers me a lot of things about the
fact the current White House bothers
bother me but what is particularly
irritating is the way in which this was
presented as some kind of new presidency
in which these things wouldn't happen
anybody who believed that must not be
seriously this disappointed those of us
who thought well we've heard this before
feel vindicated allow me to plug my
upcoming piece in and bash affair about
tension ISM be out in like a week or so
why say that you can this is what the
June issue looks like yeah you get the
cover for this and not me no I think we
it will soon be missus onassis the
rapist isn't necessary I'm not quite
sure what the one next weekend is going
to be I should I should have
that of my fingertips but anyway
reviewing the the Clinton take on
whitewater and everything else and
trying to write against the new spin
that that's been put on it it just sort
of hit me very solidly amidships that
you can count on pension to change his
mind on practically anything if a
question of principle or difficulty
comes up and he doesn't know where this
China or Haiti or Bosnia or
gays-in-the-military
or indeed campaign finance reform but
there's one thing to which is absolutely
solidly and consistently lowering that's
a particular cabal of old mates from
Arkansas most of whom have no obvious
qualifications for the jobs that they've
got or had when they've kept them not
had to resign that's one thing on which
he does not give in there's one thing on
which you can count on him to be so I've
been consistent lest they get caught
unless they get caught and in which case
off they go back to Arkansas or whip
rounds have to be held to their
helicopter fares yes to borrow phrases
that they're pulling them Reagan's that
he borrowed from the delightful pagan
dude and where do we find such man where
do all these are consents come from what
are you writing about what are you
sending back home I will I've recently
had it had a bit of a break from what I
call trouser gate concerned with more
domestic things we've just had the
launch of the first British Trident
missile from a British nuclear submarine
off the coast of Florida which I spent a
lot of last week watching mainly though
it keeps coming back to mister Clinton
and his problems and I rather expect
that Larry Nichols reply to Paula Jenson
lawsuit is going to be taking outside of
my time later on this week though today
I expect to be spending less than my
efforts on congressman Rostenkowski by
the way how do you think that you think
this will play back there and this is
Patti Davis the daughter of Ronald
Reagan playboy coming out soon I think
it may be great a mention or two yes one
now that we finally get to see the
pictures that are retriever
yeah good Labrador you do you have any
comment on that
no no I well no I don't is there a
reason why you don't have any comment on
this
mmm-hmm no there isn't even a reason I
10:20 come on gotta go the phones here
and then in just a few moments as we
kick off this week of family connections
just want to say something about trouser
Kate um the Holderman diaries reminded
me which is why I've been reading all
week unbelievably interesting in the
revelation of the mind of the Knicks in
reading the cd-rom version or just know
what I'm gonna get that I think I'm just
going to finally convert me to the new
tech it reinforced my resolution not to
do any more gate stuff because I it
brought back to me William sapphires
confession that it was he who came up
with the idea of putting gate on the end
of every minor scandal so as to make
Watergate which was a real scandal and
very nearly a coup against democracy in
America looked like just another scandal
by comparison and so I think a
self-denying ordinance should should be
made by all them all journalists to be
very careful with the gate suffix unless
they think they're onto something really
major and if you want to know what
something really major is and refresh
your memory after the terrible month of
euphemism and airbrushing that we
endured after Nixon died you should read
the whole of in Diaries and see what a
very narrow escape the country had Peter
Hitchens have you realm know I've seen a
lot of the extracts and I've been
actually surprised by the amount of
anti-semitism that they reveal
particularly I do wanted one to get
older the cd-rom version which sounds
like like an astonishing way of
presenting a diary and one which other
people will may not be following all
over the place as for all we knew about
the anti-semitism that we well it wasn't
it wasn't perhaps as clearly known about
in as graphic as it does as it is pretty
gross I mean actually say it was the
House Committee the people Dino chair at
the time had to keep on that's what the
expiry of deleted stuff originally meant
there were things they didn't think that
people could possibly face knowing about
what the president said when we're black
or Jewish Americans who've been
discussed as are believing and
practicing racist and not a single
person who wrote his any facilities or
spoke papers commemorations care to
mention the federal or or even face it
we're going to go to the phone's before
we do just to pass on you here's a
little story that some of you and the
West Coast can read you
sitting other papers written by jane
holl the new york-based writer for the
Los Angeles Times and it says FX affects
c-span viewership we pass it on to you
because for some of you and about 1.1
million homes in this country this will
be the last day that you have the
complete c-span available to you and if
you have questions don't panic don't
call your cable operator until there's
really a reason to tomorrow would be the
day if we're not there tomorrow you'll
know that something's happen and if you
see a thing called FX there that means
that it's a new channel owned by Rupert
Murdoch on your television dial
hopefully we'll be back someday and we
sure appreciate your loyalty and your
viewership if you have a question about
all this why don't you give us a call
during the working hours here at 202 7 3
7 3 2 - oh if you weren't informed of
this and your bill 30 days ago it won't
happen and it's in an isolated area a
lot of little systems in Iowa will be
off tomorrow and we apologize for the
confusion on all this but we thought we
better pass it on to you and if you have
a question again call us but don't panic
until it is absolutely gone and in most
places 99% of you will still have c-span
when you turn on the dial tomorrow let's
go to the phones we've got a Chesapeake
Virginia first up go ahead please good
morning mom I think this is an
interesting way of getting divergent
views by having a couple of brothers
there I've noticed that you've tried to
get divergent views before and ended up
with two people who should have been
opposed sitting there agreeing with with
each other I wanted to comment about
President Clinton's lack of military
experience as a retired military person
and I consider myself a moderate
conservative Republican I just don't
have any confidence that he believes in
anything particularly in in foreign
policy and when I contrast him with Bush
who served with Reagan who
didn't but at least believed in
something and stood for what he believed
in
with Carter who served with Ford who
served I just don't have any confidence
that he has a clue about using force not
to conquer everybody in the world but at
least in a way that would make us appear
to be somebody that the rest of the
world would look up to and I'd be
interested in the comments of your of
your room yes Peter Hitchens well I'm
trying to agree that the defining moment
for me of President Clinton's time in
office will always remain the moment
when news was brought to him at a
conference with radio talk-show hosts
that Alexander Ruth sky had declared
himself the alternative president of
Russia
now anybody knowing anything whatsoever
about the subject would realize this was
an immensely serious and dangerous
moment the chief executive giggled and
said isn't this funny and
here was a man who simply did not
understand her later on after he'd been
in the room with all his brief hasn't
been told presumably who Alexander would
sky was and what it meant he became very
serious and grave but I think this is a
man completely without vision whether
it's because he's never served in the
military I don't know but I think that
he he covers up his lack of a worldview
with the tremendous amount of knowledge
and that is all he has of the president
I don't think that's a particularly
serious test to a fella and it makes me
really cringe to think of what Reagan
would have done if that sort of news has
been brought to him and the the caller
was I think Ryan saying about Reagan
well I guess he didn't serve what I said
earlier well it sure Peters Reagan
didn't surf dodged it and lied about it
and twice claims to have been in uniform
in the Second World War and I've just
noticed that the people would make this
a test of Bill Clinton's integrity tend
to be Reaganites
and
to have swallowed that appalling insult
from him well he was he was he was he
was in the hell there's barely see and
therefore I don't blame him for not
being in uniform I don't blame him for
not serving I pay me for lying twice
about having served the the fell
consequence of this in the worst
consequence I can see is that President
Clinton is over impressed by callers
like the last one who are basically full
of military bluster and he's only too
willing to oblige the Joint Chiefs when
they tell him to do or not to do
something because he's terrified of
having another row with the Armed Forces
and as a result the whole principle of
civilian control of the Armed Forces and
the idea of a commander-in-chief as
someone who gives orders and doesn't
take them from the military has been
abandoned by the president with with I
think terrible consequences around not
Laurel New Jersey our next hi I'd like
to ask a simple question saying that
these two seemingly intelligent British
men what is their take on American
health care kind of with the view in
mind of what tried to be done in Britain
by the British government
thanks terrifying it's it's the the
daily nightmare threatens health care
the health care you that you have here
I'm I'm constantly scared stiff by it I
can't believe that mercy has a price on
it and having grown up in in a country
where it is simply accepted that if you
fall ill you will be treated and it's
not a question of how much money you
have or which credit card you carry to
be in a country where it seemed to be
natural that if you are ill you will pay
for it and that if you were ill for a
long time you'll pay for it until you
haven't got any money left is the
starting well we're supposed to disagree
and we generally do but I mean I agree
with all of that Doug as a country where
people are really frightened including
people very well pay like myself because
what might happen if they got sick or
almost unthinkable and I've know people
get into real trouble with this if we
have two members of the family get sick
at the same time that's it it could be
the end there's only one principle upon
which health care could possibly further
than that is you are treated according
to how sick
you are and that's the main criterion
that isn't even mentioned in the
healthcare debate now as a peasant even
as the shadow of the principal I cracked
my ribs quite badly and in the trouble
snow in January and ice I had to go to
the emergency room
if I'd be but much worse off it would
have been insufferable to go through
what I had to go through but with credit
rate checks what I could barely speak
before I was allowed into an emergency
room where I had to share a bed with
somebody else and then pay for that on
top was unbelievable
combinations of banana republic and and
and and clip joint and moral blackmail
people get charged for the operating
table
I actually charge for the operating
table that what it must be the price of
the table I you look at these bills I
went on as soon as I came here to my
neighboring Hospital in Bethesda
Suburban Hospital and they very kindly
showed me the kind of prices people were
paying for treatment and they were
ashamed of what they were showing me and
makers they just couldn't they
themselves couldn't justify try getting
a lawyer if you if you are rich as well
even the president of ice is having
difficulty with that means that the most
basic services that's why I'm known
that's why I'm a socialist from each
according to his ability to each
according to his need I don't have
anything to do with socialism any any
civilized country especially a rich
capitalist country should be far more
concerned about health care I think
those Americans who live next the
Canadian border have realized that there
is an alternative Martinez California
good morning sorry yes it's not really
interesting I've long thought that even
though most of the people in power in
the United States are European Americans
shall we say very little awareness or
interaction with European sorts of
systems and a reality is never allowed
in this country I mean we don't ever
compare those well what do we you know
doing compared to France or England and
kind of strange but I also I wanted to
call and compliment Christopher for his
book I read the sake of argument but the
other one come across it for mr. lambs
very good book notes show/hide me did
you come across it by any chance from
try to ingratiate myself here mr. lamb
very mr. Lounds very good book now
I always try to catch I do miss it
sometimes and I but I cut you on NPR
yesterday I was on the phone actually
when they couldn't take any more calls
and a woman had just called you
supercilious or something and I want I
really want to get on and tell her that
just try your book because I found it
very uh very immoral and very well I
could have done with you yesterday thank
you
Riaan live yesterday I was live at MP I
said you extremely can I say seriously I
was saying that in debate with my friend
Larry Nelson of Newsday's brilliant
reporter but rather soft on Clinton we
were reviewing the presidency I was
being quite critical almost everybody
who called up was a Clinton ID which
didn't surprise me particularly because
of the NPR audience but almost all of
them drew attention to fair that I was
foreign-born and I was interested in
this because in ten twelve years of
checking Reagan and Bush many of the
people who must have been thinking if he
doesn't like it why doesn't he clear off
back to him and so politely didn't bring
it up didn't make a big thing that
Robert Novak did once that was about it
I mean the cars didn't walk around your
callers generally don't even when
they're very angry with me but all these
NPR liberals did and I thought it was an
interesting sign of a success of Clinton
appealing to the provincial in the
American mentality and the successfully
making people feel that way
well I'd never thought that you could be
a foreigner here for very long it's the
country in which you almost immediately
but it can become accepted whoever you
are if an American came to Britain and
started making criticisms of the kind
that we make I think you'd have a very
hard time because we have real
foreigners in England if you're a
foreigner than you are four enough for
five or six generations before anyone
even dreams of accepting you it's a big
difference I've noticed here that people
simply don't have that prejudice against
outsiders that we have that's quite true
and and and a real tribute to the
National manners which is why I was so
struck yesterday by this instant so
resort to the provincial in the
chauvinistic which um well I don't want
to complain about it being English is
not being oppressed minority exactly I
don't to be sad self pity but I was just
struck by the way that that was the
first thing they went for
next call from one of the president's
hometowns Hot Springs Arkansas good
morning Brian
thank you and also thank you for the
nice bookmark from the bookmark show
thanks I'm glad you got it that's taken
yes yes it did but really I was so
thankful I came in and I waved the
envelope to my husband as I made it I
made it I made it I didn't you know I
should tell you but if you don't mind am
interested' straight one second for you
folks that don't know this so we offer
death for the first 500 that wrote us a
commemorative bookmark on our five year
anniversary of booknotes and we didn't
know whether we were going to get 500
letters or not in fact we got 9,000 and
instead of we sent everybody one I mean
we weren't trying there wasn't a trick
to the 500 we had no idea how many would
would want it and we had a bunch made up
that's why it took so long but I'm glad
you got it oh well thank you so much you
you you are very very nice now I heard
let's say I gotta separate the tooth
Christopher I believe it was who said a
while ago President Reagan lied twice
about serving that man was in the Air
Force during World War two I don't care
what he did or did not do but his vision
which should not be forgotten about his
vision is what kept him out he had to I
forget who the gentleman's names were I
saw it not too long ago in print but if
he had been allowed to be in active
service instead of what he did back here
in the country for this country he would
have either killed somebody or gotten
killed himself because of his lack of
vision for someone who is nearsighted I
have always been there sighted I can
understand that
very clearly I have often wondered what
it would be like before I had my
cataract surgeries I have often wondered
what it would be like to have vision
that you could see everything at a
distance
let me ask you though this question are
you critical of President Clinton for
not having served
oh very sir that is one of the things
that really irritates me about this
administration as Rush Limbaugh has said
many many times this is the worst we
have had 50 years okay let you go mr.
hetson's your is a vision thing a new
take on the vision thing I don't mean to
be heartless about anybody's short lord
nearsightedness and I made no allegation
that President Reagan had done anything
dishonourable in not serving I say did
something dishonorable in lying and
claiming to have served on active
service and to and in lying about having
helped to liberate the concentration
camps that's an extraordinary piece of
fantasy on his part and an insult to
this who did take part and and forgiven
him by the sort of people who quote Rush
Limbaugh when they're reaching for
authority we we care about these things
because we think that military service
and exposures of fire is a test of
character and a fairly reliable one I
think one of the things that you can say
about Ronald Reagan is that he is an
amount of physical courage after all he
made his living as a life saver and
that's not something which which
involves standing by and letting things
happen as to as to his shortsightedness
I don't I don't think this is why do you
know as it should have been but it's
certainly incorrect to say he didn't he
didn't serve was a mocking for for a
lack of courage Abe and Andy Rosenthal
father and son tomorrow our guests
Fayetteville Arkansas go ahead please
yes I'd like to say what I thought
happened to Reagan during the war he was
slightly death and the reason that he
was slightly death was that he had been
a lifeguard and as a lifeguard he had
nothing to prove about bravery he saved
75 people from drowning and don't forget
that he who keeps the baggage also
serves let me ask you though again color
the issue his do you do you get upset
with the fact that the President Clinton
hasn't served yes I do I have a bumper
sticker on the front of my car that
reads a draft dodger for as commander in
chief and on the back I have one that
says
howard phillips for president in 96 all
right thanks
Tennessee to be able to decide which of
Reagan's shortcomings physical foot come
has kept him out but I no one has taken
me up on my point but it's I know what
it's it brings back to me what it was
like arguing the Reaganites when he was
in power no one will challenge me when I
say that he twice claimed to have taken
part in active service and no one will
charge me two scenes when I surf think
that's a bit of a disgrace but we're
great about they just don't they never
hear that stuff then it makes no
difference telling them which yeah which
one of you is the older he is now what's
the difference in age two and a half
years yep oh are you married you have
children with you here yes how old are
the kids
my daughters ten and my son is five how
are they doing well it's very different
for them from Moscow where they were
before I it's also striking for me how
very different the Americans raised
their children if a friend of ours says
America's raise kids the British bring
up children and the contrast is enormous
we intend to go back to England and so I
want to bring them up as English
children when my daughter comes home I
don't let her speak American which I see
is a completely different language in
which people behave in a completely
different way and it's actually one of
the reasons why I often wonder about
whether I would in the long term like to
stay if the chance came my way I'm not
entirely sure that I want to bring my
children up as Americans needles
California needles California you're on
the air you know needles California yes
ma'am okay yes that he doesn't have any
core of support such as Reagan had
that's going to believe that he did
whatever he did and you have people like
a Christopher Hitchens who loves to
second-guess the president
I mean Christopher Hitchens isn't going
to suffer whether any health care plan
goes through not really suffer yes ton
of dough so is the editor of The New
York Times the main concern in life is
the fine points of fly-fishing
no matter what he says in his editorials
and this this is the problem for Clinton
and as far as Jerry Brown is concerned I
would like to remind mr. Hitchens about
a few things about Jerry Brown when he
was the governor of California this was
documented in the LA Times
he used the state computer systems for
voting re-election he also sold
judgeships also documented in the New
York in the Los Angeles Times and he was
one of the most obscene fundraisers for
the state Democratic Party and then he
gets this this you know bursts of things
so he can so he can wreck the candidacy
of Clinton and all of you guys are
cheering you just give up your fancy
suits when you decide to be a man of the
people
I see why I bring out that reaction some
people I think it's not true that some
tension doesn't have a core of support I
think there are there are people who
will forgive him almost anything I I
don't know quite why he has this
following but I but I know that he does
have it what you say about Brown is new
to me I didn't get your point about the
computer I'd be very surprised Jade sold
judgeships but it's certainly true that
when he ran last he did run as someone
who was forever confessing that he'd
been very involved in them in the
political corruption of fundraising and
said that he came to came to it in other
words as a reformed character the idea
of the reformed characters are obviously
a bit of a dodgy one but I thought it's
better late than never
and I thought he ran a very good
campaign on that issue and changed to
some extent of anyway the way in which
people thought about the axiomatic
domination of politics by the dollar and
it's keeping it up with what I think is
a very good radio show I think there's
always a parallel in journalists
becoming supporters of political figures
it's much more comfortable and much
easier and actually probably much safer
to stay as an opponent and critic of all
of them I think the problem that the
Americans have with their political
leaders is that they require leaders who
were partly kings and in the case of
Regan particularly many people looked
upon him as an ideal American monarch
and were prepared in my view probably
rightly to overlook a huge number of
faults because he embodied so very well
the kind of America they wanted to have
there are obviously people who feel the
same way about Clinton there is a fax
here from bob Haber of Chicago Illinois
three lines the Hitchens seems so
typically British self-confident and
reserved might we get a good belly laugh
from both of them this morning to prove
their human characteristics no it's bit
early I bet he got my teeth in yet I
don't know it's being being told it's
time to tell a joke it's a bit
forbidding I think Holland Michigan
you're next yep okay thank you all right
you're on the air I'm on the air now
you're on the air now
okay I I can't hear anybody else but I
think it's a rather presumptuous for
these gentlemen to be talking about our
health care system when they obviously
do not understand it my husband is a
physician he writes off forty-seven
percent of his care of patients because
he wants to be sure that all people are
cared for and you would be amazed at the
number of doctors that do this most
doctors do this in the United States
healthcare is available to people if
they need health care why is it that so
many people are coming from Canada to
the United States we have a very close
friend who works a person who is a
fellow in England in the renal dialysis
unit and he said that in their renal
dialysis unit when people reach the age
of 55 they come in and at that time they
get a birthday cake and are told they've
had a good life in the United States
will do renal dialysis on people who are
80 years old don't talk to me about a
healthcare system that runs short on
dollars and then figures that people
beyond 55 60 don't have the value of
another person thanks Peter Hitchens
don't believe the story and would would
love to hear a chapter and verse on it
it wouldn't make the most amazing
scandal in the British press if such a
thing were said to anybody as us the
rest of it why shouldn't I understand it
after all I don't have the British
National Health Service here I've had to
make my own arrangements and I found the
process extremely frightening and I've
been and visited several hospitals and
talked to a large number of doctors
including one doctor who like your
husband I said that he did give free
care to his patients but found that his
usual reward was to get sued in
malpractice cases because people felt
that it was their chance in the great
American legal lottery to get their
slice of the cake and he didn't find it
a very edifying experience no I don't
think your health care system stands out
to examination right and I'd love to
know how many people are coming from
Canada in the United States to get
health care
maybe this'll help the guy from Chicago
who thought we were being too pompous
and solemn or from it was Illinois
wasn't it caught you in The New Yorker a
few years ago of a fat man standing in a
robe and a harp on a cloud talking to
another guy who dogs had just got into
heaven and saying well I did have hate
in my heart but it was for doctors and
lawyers and they said that was okay
that's as good as it gets Chicago
Deerfield Deerfield Beach Florida go
ahead there feel Beach Florida go ahead
you're on there Brian I want to thank
you for the d-day Expo that you had I
was really really touched I was only six
years old when the war began but I grew
up and I was 11 at the time of d-day and
listening to vera-ellen and watching it
was really really touching setting that
aside I saw mr. Clinton place the wreath
at the Unknown Soldier yesterday and I
cried again because I am appalled that
this man well protest against our
country it's just growing up during the
war and watching this man who really
protests against this country is
different than Christopher Hitchens
saying that Reagan did not serve in the
war know what no one will take up my
actual point mr. Hitchens and another
thing Peter I've watched you and admired
you before but the fact that you just
made a derogatory remark about the
Americans that you Americans just bring
up their children and brick raised them
Americans Americans raised kids and this
isn't my original statement but it seems
to some about rather well Americans
raised kids the English bring up their
children bringing up the Beatles and
they came here and wrecked our country
that's all I've got I apologize for that
it wasn't my fault it was the moving
students who wrecked the country they're
also British
Clinton did not protest against his
country if you want to take a look at
the Haldimand ayahs and see how Nixon
and Kissinger discussed the waging of
that war and the timing of the bombing
to affect the election and the
deliberate prolonging of the war to save
their own skins and how they probably
were individually responsible for the
deaths of maybe 20,000 Americans in the
years between 68 and 72 and finally
settled on the terms which they had run
against in an election which they tried
to some third you would say it wasn't
just your right as an American to
protest against that war it was your
civic duty and to the extent that
Clinton took any part in the anti-war
movement he deserves great credit my
quarrel with him is he doesn't seem to
have the residue of courage from that
period and that will be required to say
as he could have said in response to
Reagan's big lie that the Vietnam War
was a noble cause that the anti-war
movement was the noble cause and let's
have the national discussion about that
fax from Sierra Madre California Jack
Calloway question to me is c-span going
to be carried on Direct TV we've lost
you spend two full time maybe maybe
worse to come
thanks to all at c-span the answer is
yes we will be on DirecTV go c-span one
and two and it'll be available
nationwide on October the first as we go
to Little Rock California go ahead
please I'm Brian I have three comments
Brian will give me time to make them yes
you can
I admired Clinton for having the nerve
and the courage to protest against
Vietnam Vietnam was the biggest joke
that ever was okay now that's what he
done and you can see his friend written
on his forehead Ronald Reagan I'm amazed
and apploud and how he has managed to do
the Americans I'm an Aries foreign
person but I live in America for 33
years he did this country arrived the
jobs to Walken and bio and then went
after he was out of office to collect
his check also no one ever mentions the
fact that Nancy Reagan went out of
office with millions of dollars for just
say no to drugs and
done nothing with it but open a big
office in Century City and absolutely
does nothing with it you know I I just
maybe it's British and Irish people we
can see things because we're not
directly involved as Americans but to me
the only thing that there differs
between Clinton and and and Reagan as
far as what Clinton did Reagan was an
actor it was a biggest phony they ever
hit the President of the United States
and I'm we're suffering
we've got homeless on our streets we've
got poverty the likes of you never seen
he started tribalism among our people
how long have you been here from Ireland
alright thanks got your point you know
now no no you must be pleased to know
that there are people out there who are
who are backing you are amazing you say
that Clinton has no acting ability I
think the president isn't is a superb
performer and I still like to replay his
State of the Union message for the sheer
delight of the performance as opposed to
the substance of it as from Vietnam I
don't know I protested against it at the
time but looking back on it I wonder
whether it's exactly marvelous that
Vietnam has now ruled from Hanoi by one
of the last Leninist clicks on the face
of the earth and is one of the most
poverty stricken and miserable countries
in Southeast Asia and whether perhaps
there wasn't a cause there that has got
forgotten in all the agonizing about
whether American kids who have gone to
fighting that in the war Columbus Ohio
okay hi how are you fine I'd like to ask
Peter Hitchens a question regarding Iraq
as I understand it there was a
investigation recently as to I forgotten
the name of this building Clarion
rearming of Iraq other ideas and and its
relationship to the BNL bank in Atlanta
and and my real question is this seems
to have been more prominent in the news
in England and here in the United States
we constantly talk about Bill Clinton's
failures in foreign policy but very
little
said about George Bush's role in
rearming Iraq which is far more critical
and and my real question is how does the
the sale of futures which leads to a
profit by a first lady get to be bigger
news in the sale of arms that leads to a
war well I think the sale of arms leads
to war the existence of the Saddam
Hussein regime in Iraq certainly leads
to Wars I think you'll find that most
countries in the world whether it be the
former Soviet Union the present Russia
the United States France Britain South
Africa Israel that can make money out of
selling arms do so and will continue to
do so wherever they can but to blame the
sale of those arms to the war which
follows is absurd
Tom Rizzo of Akron Ohio has a fracture
can I go back that seemed to get this in
quickly
invite comments from the brothers
Hitchens on these topics Labour Party
after John Smith will it ever find its
way back to the left no it seems to me a
preordained in fact that preordained
conclusion that the mantris hadn't wised
on it but he's actually claims to have
modelled himself on on Bill Clinton
Mackel Tony Blair is gonna win because
everyone in the press tells him that's
the only way from win the election Tony
Blair will be the new leader a new
ability later their party he'll lose the
election
41 yeah for that reason wrong wrong on
both counts actually took Tony um who I
know does not mugged himself on Clinton
was rather embarrassed by the
comparisons made between him and Clinton
to he's by no means certain to win the
leadership because the Labor Party is
actually has no members to speak of
except a small group of people who know
they're right and who are quite capable
of picking another losing leader and may
well do so in the next few months been
wattenberg and his son Daniel who is
with the American Spectator Ben what
Mirza columnist and has his own program
called think tank will be here on
Thursday morning Arlington Virginia go
ahead please
good morning Brian just a quick preface
I certainly don't find either of the
mister Hitchens's to be supercilious or
overly British at all living here inside
the beltway they
just as just as normal as anybody in
politics around here is likely to be
found a quick question for each one of
them for Christopher I've been a loyal
supporter of Ronald Reagan since the mid
80s and our excuse me since the mid-70s
and I am not familiar with the speeches
that he refers to and I'd like to take
him up on his point as to when mr.
Reagan claimed to have served where he
didn't or have liberated concentration
camps or something of that sort Kenny
tell me where this happened well yeah
and I don't blame me for not knowing
because it was something that didn't fit
into the press coverage because if it
was true he was doing this then she was
getting to be a great communicator would
would look ridiculous wouldn't they the
occasion where he claimed to have helped
to liberate the concentration house was
during the visit by the attack Shamir
who was then the Foreign Minister of
Israel Raiden claimed this to mr. shamea
in the White House he later claimed it
when he was visited by Simon Wiesenthal
the I think slightly exaggerated Nazi
hunter from Austria I can give you
chapter and verse references for both
those claims by the by the then
president if you wish your action car
I mean I would certainly have an open
mind about it and it would if it turned
out to be something he said and not just
a slip of the tongue reading something
none of us wouldn't did he you wouldn't
it's the either you did help deliberate
Dachau or you didn't would be live you
and if you thought you hadn't you hadn't
you be in some kind of quite severe
delusional condition and that would
certainly lower the reputation of the
ex-president in my mind Connor did you
have to see 60 minutes on Sunday night
yes as a matter of fact about the the
people who claim to have gotten medals
that they didn't well they had the story
there about Ronald Reagan telling that
story about the c-17 and the Medal of
Honor winner which they said turned out
to be fantasy and just came from a movie
yeah well this is certainly possible I
wonder who I wonder who did his research
for him as we say I doubt if he did it
himself
okay thanks Arlene I'm sorry we go to
San Diego California go ahead please
good morning gentlemen
first off I'd like to say mr. Hitchens
if I have to
allegations that mr. Reid and Sapphire
and The Economist magazine have made
this white water makes Watergate look
like a stroll through the park but my
question is this The Economist magazine
on May 7th put in an article about a
gentleman named Dennis Patrick who was
involved in trading with the last turf
company involving a some odd twenty
thousand dollars he was promised since
then he's had four attempts on his life
and is now underground and hiding and
I'm wondering why this story is not
being reported by our press we have to
hear about it in a European magazine
thanks well if I can draw attention yet
again to my forthcoming column and
actually fair I do go into the last of
connection in Arkansas which is I think
the least noticed aspect of the
whitewater entanglement so I hope I
couldn't I hope I can look you in the
eye and and say that much and I thought
the Economist story was pretty good and
it's not the only place that it's
appeared but it's probably the longest
take on it I just have to disagree with
you there even though I'm trying to
boost my own piece in saying that it
makes Watergate look like a stroll
through the park so far it hasn't
I think approach that for criminality
but it's invidious I think to seek to
compare these different kinds of of
scandal because well it's a matter of
privacy really Peter Hitchens regarding
d-day yesterday a CNN poll indicated
that just 19 percent of the British
believes America contributed the most to
winning World War two are their schools
as bad as ours or do the British see
history through a fool's fog how do you
bridge feel about the Chunnel well Cyril
our schools are nearly as bad as yours
after another mistaken attempted
egalitarianism and you have to pay a
fortune for a good education but also we
do tend to believe that we won the war
and you will find if you go to Russia
that d-day was a minor landing on the
western fringes of Europe as a not
particularly convenient moment wherever
you go these things are viewed
differently and I'm afraid that that
will always continue I've no doubt that
a lot of Americans have barely
aware that the British took part in and
the d-day landings and Canadians are
constantly furious about the fact that
nobody mentions them as for the channel
I think I hate it I see any reason for
existing i I love France enormously but
I'm delighted that there's a patch of
water between me and SM that going
anywhere in Europe involves genuinely
going abroad
and across the sea I hope they fill it
in preferably with a left over tower
block from London Jim batts Fort Worth
Texas I would like to know if the men at
airport rumors and the accusations made
by Larry Nichols against Clinton are
making the British press the liberal
media including me he says seem to be
avoiding this subject even more than
they want Savoy at Paula Jones Jim batts
and then he says deal with it Brian
well it certainly had more play in the
British press than it has here I think
probably if you said most Americans they
it would be the first time they heard it
yeah which i think is rather
extraordinary we did have something in
the nation during the election campaign
but again that was a time when Clinton
was designated moderate designated
frontrunner designated man who you know
knew how to play by the rules so none of
this stuff was allowed to come up but
meaner airports in Airport in western
Arkansas which was used as one of the
staging post for the Contra resupply
operation which was a criminal
conspiracy at the time involving
basically the exchange of illegal
weapons for illegal drugs but whether
one lot of thugs in the United States
supported and trained another lot of
thugs in Nicaragua I'm obliged to have
been turned by mr. Fenton's
administration in Arkansas about about
this David few stole at Fort Wayne
Indiana sends this in I just want to ask
what's going on that we get two faxes
from two different parts of the country
on this subject do you have any comments
about the rumors about drug gun running
at the Mena Airport in Arkansas they
might know where it's come from it just
seems to be the conspiracy theory of the
month to me it's it's it's one of those
things where as soon as you see people
saying to me
Clinton the CIA
Colombian drug barons the Contras he
begin to think well maybe just possibly
it might be sooner or later someone may
find out
in 2007 this is true but it just seems
thoroughly unlikely to me and not to the
point it's it draws attention away from
the main issues of what happened in
Arkansas which is people behaved in ways
which if they were legal was certainly
not terribly ethical Jackson Mississippi
thanks for waiting
thank you good morning I'm gonna speak
from the heart this morning when I got
normally too but the reason I'm calling
is mr. Hitchens I really believe that
conspiracies are a fact because these
people in power are not gonna allow
things to happen without orchestrating
things ahead of time they don't just
allow things just to fall on them and
happen and I think what's happening with
c-span losing c-span in certain parts of
the country my fellow Americans we
better wake up c-span is our only true
honest voice in this country and the
little bits of the country that c-span
is losing these people in power are not
going to take c-span off the air right
away they're going to do it bit by bit
they're gonna add your way at it because
c-span is making a difference and it's
making a difference in our attitudes
we're getting the truth the facts about
the things that have happened around the
world the Palestinians for instance the
things that we've been fed through the
media through special interest groups
we're getting facts on c-span if you
glean what people say and do research on
your own and I'll tell you we need to
call our congressmen because something's
happening and I would like c-span to be
taken over by the federal government
unbiased and partisan and let Brian lamb
become a federal employee and we can get
more honest feed on what is happening
around the world because we are not
getting it from these publications and
from the network media thanks don't know
where to start with that one
I think we should take it as a comment
it wasn't a question right but then
you'll enjoy this comment from e Taryn
TN excuse me of Lewisburg Tennessee
Brian maybe you should do a weekend of
Revolutionary War highlights so we can
all remind ourselves why we parted ways
with these soup
silliest snobs in the first place the
warning today would be one if by land
two if by sea three if by TV enough but
I would like to claim the American
Revolution as part of an English
revolution all the same it was basically
a revolution of highly educated English
people against a German monarchy and
it's German
sorry good forces in America they cite
them to me is that the German monarchy
still remains in England and the
American Revolution is to that extent
incomplete but I but I very much admire
the spirit and some extent the letter of
that that fact supercilious snob you you
buy that you can tell they're all
supercilious not patrol the trouble with
Americans is that they're constantly
having masterpiece theater rammed down
their throat as the New York Times
rightly pointed out last week if they
could see real British TV they could
realize what a tremendous minority the
supercilious snobs are and how the real
Brit whom they would have seen only
Indian had a team in the World Cup is
very different from from Christopher and
me by the way is snooker real British TV
I'm afraid it is yes yep since color
television arrived though all those
colored balls whirling around make a
very nice picture on them Mountain Lakes
New Jersey go ahead place oh hello I
would like to resort both messages to
continue being supercilious noses it's
very amusing I'm enjoying it
tremendously
I've lived in England and parts of
Europe for the past 25 years then
dragged kicking and screaming back to my
homeland by my husband's work I've had
excellent care under the National Health
Service in Britain and several other
socialized medical services I would like
to know what your guests would feel
could be learnt from the present state
of the British Health System which could
aid America setting up a good clear
adapt for us so where are you where you
from what you call homeland I was born
in the United States but have lived much
of my life in England thanks gentlemen
well I haven't I haven't though I was
brought up on free blackcurrant juice
and milk which was given to all English
children and abolished the deficiency
disease problems of rickets and other
calcium deficiency
afflictions that have been such a big
feature of English life before the
Second World War I don't have any
real-time knowledge of how the National
Health Service is now doing I just think
that it's it's a very plain statement of
principle that any advance of civilised
country should treat people according
not to how well-off they are but how
sick they are and I've no doubt that
that would need some adaptation for
American conditions but that is the
principle on which um we were brought up
and which we take for granted and
wouldn't give up for anything and nor
would the United States if it could
in-state the principle in the first
place I think the fundamental lesson is
that if you have a viable private health
system as Britain did before the
National Health Service you need a great
deal of political courage and direction
to achieve a health service which is
open to everybody we were very lucky in
that the man who set this up nya Bevan
was able to make the case for such a
system not merely to the public but also
to the doctors and persuade them that
their position would not be threatened
by in fact private medicine survives in
Britain alone does very well and it's
largely because of that that the health
services lasted as long as it has
misguided attempts to drive private
medicine underground and to force it out
of the health service have actually led
to us rather sad growth in private
medicine in Britain in the past few
years which is undermining the quality
of the health service Pasadena
California good morning Brian
thank you picking up now Christopher's
almost awake I think by the end of this
show he'll be with us I'm calling to to
defense Clinton on the anti-war issue I
agree with Christopher he said he sort
of taken this opportunity early to be as
eloquent as he wasn't that letter that
was raised that he didn't want to go up
to Vietnam to kill people he then
thought that the world was immoral I
think if he had said that but I would
like to hear in this week before d-day
is some veterans like my late father who
by the time my my
was of draft age towards the end of
Vietnam I said was about prepared to
break his kneecaps rather than send him
off even though he had been aware my
father had been a Marine and to him
draft avoidance was the worst possible
thing in the world I think that he would
have you know run him to Canada broke
his kneecap so I'd like to hear from
some of those veterans I know that they
had son who didn't go to camos who
didn't go to Vietnam who perhaps went to
Canada and I think that that's the that
the hostility bubbling underneath done
boiled everything I just hope you had a
wonderful picture you were holding up a
few minutes ago I think from USA Today
of the president standing beside a
general singing the national anthem with
four most unbelievable vigor I this is
not a man who looks as if he spend very
much time avoiding going to Vietnam I
don't think he believes now that he
should have done it
and I think that that is in some ways
why he's so open to criticism if if he
if he stuck by it if on the other hand
he he'd done it in a more
straightforward way but as I said he did
not do it in a straightforward way now
he pretends that he is more patriotic
than the generals I think he's always
gonna be in a fix about this and I'm
interested I've been trying to convince
myself because as everyone in Washington
says you should be careful not to let
your your own opinions take over I've
been trying to convince myself that he
is in fact going to be a successful
candidate in 1996 but I begin to see
signs especially in the in the weekend
opinion polls that people are perhaps
beginning to look at him as a one-term
president and I think this may be a
major factor in this cannot Kent Ohio go
ahead please yeah hi you're a wonderful
show thanks a lot thanks in response to
Christopher Hitchens and Ronald Reagan's
service I looked it up in an American
Life which is his autobiography and he
talks about getting his draft notice
immediate action and then he went and it
was his eyes but then he was confined to
Continental limits eligible for core
area service commander were Department
overhead and he served
an officer liaison officer for a few
months and then went to the army or Army
Air Corps intelligence actually was a
second lieutenant were second lieutenant
bars and he it says in here I was
wearing bars of a second lieutenant I
was offering majors and seniors to half
a million dollar-a-year directors and
they went on to make movies then and
then if you read on further this is like
page 97 of his autobiography
it says during the final months of war
we began receiving secret single-core
films showing the liberation of Hitler's
death camps and they engraved images on
my mind that might be where you heard
that but I never heard that Ronald
Reagan said that he liberated death
camps no my fool did you haven't no but
you said now by the way J Durbin and T
Durbin 602 area code say the World
Almanac and book of facts 1994 states on
page 478 Ronald W Reagan he was a
captain in the Air Force during World
War two where do their facts come from
ya know no one says he wasn't in the at
she was in the the movie making a and
from of the army made training films
that kind of thing well no one says he
didn't what what I'm saying
till I'm tired is that he came to a done
great deal more than that on several
occasions on the record that I can prove
to anybody Amarillo Texas
Thank You Bryan oh one quick comment
Christopher as far as the legal
implications of Watergate personal
whitewater I think miss Foster might
make it different with you there I was
calling I'm a proud owner of an FN FAL
which had the distinction of serving
both sides in the Falklands War a
semi-automatic assault weapon if you
will that is soon to be banned here in
this country and has been in a great
britain for several years now and I was
wondering how you feel the effects of
gun control would affect the role of
terrorism here as it has a broad thing
is that we don't really have that many B
directions well I think gun control is
possibly the most ludicrous and phoney
political issue available in any country
in the world today
in a nation where as far as I know there
are 200 million guns in private hands
the idea of controlling them is about as
realistic as controlling umbrellas it
isn't going to happen and those who
pretend that it is are duping themselves
and the public I think America missed
its chance on gun control many years ago
and went instead for prohibition which
only served to to spread the use of guns
we have a problem in Britain that guns
and are beginning to enter the country
in fairly large numbers that armed crime
is on the increase and that we are
beginning to arm our police which is a
tragedy but at least we do have the
possibility of genuine gun control of
this early stage you don't Gardena
California yeah have an a.1 comparison
like I talked about with South Africa
and the black and white situation there
and Israel and Palestine and the English
in the iris iris what you guys feel
about that okay well he's not on the
line again and I just want to show you
though it's in the news this morning of
there's several stories of Murphy here's
the LA Times Palestinians faced with
cash crisis so he's talking about the
Palestinian problem over in drop this
there's also an editorial in The
Washington Post that shin feigns Stahl
this is all about waiting for the
European elections on June the 9th so
the issues that he had talked about he's
talking about her all over the papers
what I think he was trying to say was
these were three colonial semi-colonial
comparisons I don't think there's of any
very exact comparison to be made between
any two of those let alone all three
there is there is there is one strong
parallel that in all cases there is a
group of people usually are politically
unpopular and incorrect group of people
on the territory involves which doesn't
want to leave and is challenged by
another local nationalism and that in in
all three countries this has led to
different forms of conflict and
compromise and in probably and all three
of them will eventually lead to disaster
the the South African problem is that
the
whites are not colonial whites they are
they're white Africans who have no
intention of going anywhere I've nowhere
to go if they wanted to in Northern
Ireland the the Protestant majority
which is going to become a minority and
will probably take to terrorism on its
own account and in Israel a group of
people who arrived there mainly as a
result of the Balfour Declaration in
1917 and we're not going to go but who
was surrounded on the present American
foreign policy by hostile and unreliable
States which had been forced into rather
temporary looking agreements with them
we're gonna take a total of two more
calls this one from Fairfax Virginia
next and then one more go ahead please
good morning Bryan I'm so honored to be
effecting the last caller this morning
well thank you mr. Hitchens I had a
question and I wanted to add on one
other one Iraq we had two helicopter
shot down there about 60 days ago and I
believe the Pentagon promised some sort
of a report analyzing the shoot down and
the whys and where ports I haven't seen
anything on that do you
it's kind of an insider have any idea
what the status of that report is I wish
I could say that I had nobody didn't
seem to me they would need a very
exhaustive inquiry I mean I think all
the main facts were were acknowledged on
more or less on the same day that was a
appalling of failure of aircraft
recognition and in other words the
shoot-down was done by of American
servicemen and at least some other
Western European officers and I think
some Kurds was done by American planes I
think one of the best things that the
United States is doing at the moment is
providing the the protect the military
protection under which the the Kurds are
succeeding in there were not without
great difficulty in developing a limited
autonomy and independence for the first
time in their in their long and very
bitter a struggle for freedom I did
check up on this last weekend and
nothing is apparently a minute I'm also
puzzled but it's taking so long it does
seem to be a fairly straightforward case
the work the word British
officers aboard the helicopter and
Britain has a strong interest in getting
an answer to this question well if
Philip James of Park Ridge Illinois I'm
curious does the BBC allow American
journalists to bash current and former
British leaders etc yeah and please tell
that chap from Vanity Fair that he may
wind up in the US healthcare system if
he continues seeking medals Awards for
alcohol consumption he looks rather ill
that's it you saved that for love well
no I just got it well at least I
couldn't be said to be wearing it on my
sleeve on my lapel Kansas City Missouri
you're next hi I just want to ask the
gentleman if as far as the Mena Arkansas
thing with Clinton
I'm originally from Arkansas and I know
it happened or I knew I know several
people that were somewhat involved and
they were allowed to retire from public
office is this gonna be swept under the
rug or and second question why do you
think that draft dodgers like say for
instance Jackson Browne Clinton the what
is it annoyed James what do you think
they can go and make millions of dollars
you know basically draw dodging the
draft they come back make millions of
dollars off the American people why do
you think it's so thank you hon James
fun to cool the draft told you before
that I've heard it called many things
and by the way on the other issue of the
Mena Arkansas situation here's a there's
another fax this is from Bangor Maine
from Todd Foy ask your guests what they
think about the book that Jerry Reed
wrote relating to the Mena Airport and
Bill Clinton's administration turning a
blind eye to it Jerry Reed was a pilot
in the operation was hunted along with
his family by our government because
they did not want him going public about
it also in this book it is alleged along
with other credible sources of Foster
murdered word has it that Fiske is
following a paper trail relating to
Foster's desk that's part of leading to
the Mena Airport Mena Arkansas herefor
yep I mean I get I get a call of letters
like this too very often I'm afraid to
say written in green ink which are
inclined to the view which is always
suspicious and to be guarded against
that everything's connected to
everything else I also believe there is
such a thing as conspiracy and I think
it's wrong to believe that the there is
no such thing I think the term
conspiracy theories too often use to put
an end to inquiries but there is also
such a thing as paranoia and I'm afraid
to say that a lot of the anti-clinton
letter writers and so on are suffering
from that I got a fax here for Pierre
Hitchens from the blue Mouse studio Rex
Snyder the last time you were on you
pretended not to know the meaning of
homophobia I don't think you should be
allowed to get away with that it betrays
your own homophobia to not recognize the
insanity behind the cruel treatment of a
segment of the human family that
contributes so much including by the way
war efforts perhaps your brother can
elaborate well thanks for the chance to
go back on that I was half asleep and
made a complete mess of the point I was
making the word the word simply means
fear of the same and is therefore pretty
much meaningless as for whether there is
such a thing you isn't it is is the some
point at which we say that some forms of
sexual behavior are unacceptable do we
for instance say that child molesting is
okay if not why not do we were we wrong
to draw the line at homosexuality or
something that we approved of what are
we right now to say that it's fine
is it alright for authors in rosenberg
cottages and wrong for convicts in
prison to get up to it it's a discussion
which is worth having but it's a
discussion which is not not being had at
the moment homosexuality is something
which is which is accepted without
question whereas twenty or thirty years
ago it was denounced without question I
can't help believing that there is a
debate to be had about whether it's a
good or a bad thing and we're not having
it at the moment
as the one who quote over Peter after
that show saying you've got homophobia
wrong it means fear of the same I also
have a doubt that it's the right word
because clear of the same it's not
really what's intended by those who wish
there to be a word which I think there
should be for people who are bigoted
about homosexuality it could in fact be
well if we went into it far enough that
the homophobia would accidentally turn
out to be the right word because I have
noticed in those who are extremely
prejudiced against homosexuality that
there is an insecurity about their own
sexual standing there very often a fear
that they are themselves homosexual and
ironically therefore homophobic might to
not be the right word for the moment I
think we could do with a better one
describe prejudice on its own I only
have a few moments last fact from Conway
Arkansas why did these two guys come to
America simply to critique everyone we
in Arkansas are though over the ones
left over if this is not totally but
some words left out the lowest and
everything education etc can these two
not get jobs in their country and take
their kids with them well have a job in
my country and the job that I have in my
country is to come here and report on
this one and I intend to return to it
and as as for the at the point if if
there were nothing to criticize then I'm
sure I wouldn't criticize it and you
were very welcome at any time to come to
my country ever decides it and now now
how do you feel about our strategy right
there because I don't think the single
question and we went pretty much around
the Union this morning from callers and
fighters invited us to be other than
critical about the president or the
political system so had you wanted us to
say something nice you only needed to
have asked you both were born in
Portsmouth England I was Peter was born
Malta I'm sorry that's right we've
talked about that last time now you went
to the University of York and you went
to Cambridge and Oxford other jokes
video with actually the same time as the
Pres